so here's a thought what if none of this
has ever been about the science maybe
it's always been about politics and
control joining me now to react douglas
murray author of the madness of crowds
douglas it seems to me that there was
this surprisingly negative reaction from
so many people who've bought into every
rule that they were supposed to follow
to what should be received as welcome
news
that's right and by the way i mean what
a great set of clips that was i love
that
that that boasts of the hoarding of
masks i buy just dozens of masks boxes
of masks everywhere and as for that you
just had just now this this thing of you
know uh
is it about the science or is it about
business
as if you know it's sort of one or the
other it's a zero-sum game you've either
got to listen to science or you've got
to destroy business you can't do you
can't do both of these things uh this
just demonstrates a madness that is
going on in america and around the world
about this you're absolutely right ben
there are people who are seriously
disappointed at the cdc's new guidance
any normal rational reasonable person
should be delighted that the cdc has
said that the quarantine period has gone
down from 10 days to 5. it's absolutely
in line with what we know about the
omicron variant which is that it is the
weakest and least significant variant of
this so far with the least number of
hospitalizations the least number of
deaths connected to it if omicron isn't
the moment at which you can start to cut
quarantine and much more it's hard to
know when that would be but you see a
lot of these people that you've just
cited they don't want to ever go back to
normal they they don't want to return
to the pre-covered world they love the
covet world it allows them to control
everything and everyone and to focus on
this one issue
to the to the destruction of everything
else including the economy
uh to that point uh dr fauci was asked
to address just this question just the
other day
there is the danger that there will be
so many people
who are being isolated who are
asymptomatic
for the full 10 days that you could have
a major negative impact
on our ability to keep society running
so the decision was made although it's
not completely risk-free
of saying let's get that cut in half
you know it just seems to me like this
is a scenario where he's admitting that
there's a balance here that people have
to find that balance right and something
that we should have been acknowledging
all along
you know
there are so many people in this whole
to last two years who really have so
many questions that they are going to
have to be responsible for answering at
some point in the years ahead i mean
it's not just the the issue of dr fouch
you've just listed there's a former
clinton advisor who was on social media
today saying what are they talking about
uh limiting this um children are going
to have to be going back to school and
then everyone's going to be killed again
and you know just think about this this
lack of ability to weigh up and balance
reasonably issues to do with the virus
and the threat and for instance the
education of young people in america
children in america
why is it only now that we're having
this discussion of the reasonable
balance the balance of the virus and
business people are saying that the head
of delta and other businesses who've
been calling for this reduction of
quarantine from ten days to five days
are putting business first well sure
business has to be a priority in america
the education of young people has to be
a priority in america the omicron
variant cannot be the single priority it
never should have been and the fact that
we've only just got here now is an
absolute disgrace
can't use this pandemic as a permanent
warm blanket douglas murray thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else